This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是Sam J.，我是Alex English。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全进行的诚实对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian. Michael Ranjini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这份特定的测试结果两次。我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）。迈克尔·兰吉尼（Michael Ranjini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange model.
我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身以及培养抗挫力的科学。
and worry. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
和担忧。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即“TWO percent”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to this show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners. Out listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we've got another one of our bonus episodes. These like kind of shorter coffee break style chats are when we take one psychological concept, one word that gets thrown around a lot and really just unpack what it actually means.
大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们在20年代面临的重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到这个节目。欢迎回到这个播客，新听众们。老听众们，无论你们身处世界的哪个角落，很高兴你们能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们要剖析20多岁时的心理学。今天，我们有另一期加更节目。这种类似于茶歇式的简短聊天，是我们探讨一个心理学概念，一个经常被提及的词，并真正剖析它实际含义的时候。
Normally, like we don't, like they don't really have enough content for like a whole 40 minute episode, but I still really want to deep dive into them and I still feel like there's a lot in the topic and in the conversation that we can learn from. So today is one of those episodes. And what we're talking about is something that I think we've probably all experienced, maybe not always recognized. It's also one of my favorite things to talk about in general. We're going to explore this concept of flow states.
通常，就像我们不会，这没有足够的内容量来做整整40分钟的节目，但我仍然非常想深入探讨它们，而且我仍然觉得在这个话题和对话中有很多我们可以学习的东西。所以今天就是这样的一期节目。我们要讨论的是我认为我们可能都经历过，但可能并不总是能识别出来的东西。这也是我总的来说最喜欢谈论的事情之一。我们将探讨“心流状态”（flow states）这个概念。
That sweet spot where you are so immersed in what you're doing that you just lose all sense of time. You forget to check your phone. You forget you're even you for a little while. You are just so totally in it. Maybe you have gotten this when you're doing something creative. I know for me when I'm painting, when I'm doing Sudoko, I always get into a flow state, but maybe when you're dancing, sketching, or maybe it's when you're just with your best friend. And suddenly hours fly by in a matter of minutes.
那个让你完全沉浸在所做的事情中，以至于完全失去时间感的甜点时刻。你忘记查看手机。有一会儿，你甚至忘记了自己是谁。你完全沉浸其中。也许当你做有创造性的事情时，你曾体验过这种感觉。我知道对我来说，当我画画、做数独时，我总是能进入心流状态，但也许当你在跳舞、素描，或者也许只是和最好的朋友在一起时。转眼间，几个小时在几分钟内飞逝。
It's so rare. It's this magical zone of effortless engagement that I think we could all benefit from experiencing a little bit more. So the term flow was first introduced by the Hungarian American psychologist Mihai Chiksenk Mihayi in the 1970s. In his words, the best moments in our lives are not the passive, receptive, relaxing times. The best moments usually occur when a person's body or mind is stretched to its limits in a voluntary effort to accomplish something difficult and worthwhile that is also enjoyable. He first identified this feeling by looking at some of the most talented and exceptional people in the world, athletes, ballet dances, entrepreneurs, authors, scientists, and identifying this thing that kind of linked them all together. Something they all had in common was that when they were doing the thing that they loved and that they were the best at, although they described it differently, they all had this feeling of,
这太罕见了。这是这种毫不费力的投入的魔幻地带，我认为我们所有人都能从更多地体验它中受益。因此，“心流”这个术语最早是由美籍匈牙利心理学家米哈里·契克森米哈赖（Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi）在20世纪70年代提出的。用他的话说，我们生活中最好的时刻不是那些被动、接受、放松的时刻。最好的时刻通常发生在当一个人为了完成某项困难而有价值且令人愉快的事情时，其身体或精神在自愿的努力下被拉伸到极限的时候。他最初通过观察世界上一些最有才华、最杰出的人物来识别这种感觉，比如运动员、芭蕾舞演员、企业家、作家、科学家，并找出了将他们所有人联系在一起的东西。他们所有人都有一个共同点，那就是当他们在做自己热爱且最擅长的事情时，尽管他们的描述各不相同，但他们都有这样一种感觉：
flow, that they said told them almost, made them feel like, even if they never found success, they were on the right path. They wanted to chase this feeling. Chikset Mihai actually outlined the eight main characteristics of flow that he identified in all these different cases. See if you kind of align with any of these. See if these have been your experience. The first was intense focus and concentration. Whatever you are doing, you are completely absorbed. The second is merging of action and awareness. You stop thinking about what you're doing.
心流，他们说这几乎告诉他们，让他们觉得，即使他们从未取得成功，他们也是走在正确的道路上。他们想要追逐这种感觉。契克森米哈赖实际上概述了他在所有这些不同案例中识别出的心流的八个主要特征。看看你是否符合其中任何一个。看看这些是否是你的经历。第一是强烈的专注力和注意力。无论你在做什么，你都完全沉浸其中。第二是行动与意识的融合。你不再去想你在做什么。
You just do it. Third, loss of self-consciousness. You forget to be self-critical. Even if you have the loudest inner critic, when you're in a state of flow, they are nowhere to be seen. Fourth, a sense of control. You feel capable, balanced between challenge and skill. Fifth is a distorted sense of time.
你只是去做。第三，自我意识的消失。你忘记了自我批判。即使你有最吵闹的内在批评者，当你处于心流状态时，他们也无影无踪。第四，掌控感。你感到能力充沛，在挑战和技能之间保持平衡。第五，扭曲的时间感。
The hours literally feel like minutes. You look up, it's like you started at 2. It's 8pm. Sixth, there is clear goals and feedback. You know what you're doing and you can see how you're doing. Seventh is a sense of effortlessness. You're working hard, but it doesn't feel hard. You don't feel like you're becoming exhausted.
几个小时感觉就像几分钟。你抬头一看，就像是你2点开始的。现在是晚上8点。第六，有清晰的目标和反馈。你知道自己在做什么，并且能看到自己做得怎么样。第七，毫不费力的感觉。你在努力工作，但并不觉得困难。你不会觉得自己精疲力竭。
and eight is something called an autotelic experience, meaning that you are doing this thing for its own sake, not for a reward, not for an audience. If nobody ever acknowledged what you were doing, you would still do it every single day if you could. Even though Cheek sent Mihayi gave it a modern label, the experience of flow, it's actually not modern at all. Throughout history, people have described something striking, similar. For example, ancient Greek philosophers talked about eudamonia, a state of human
第八种被称为“自体目的体验”（autotelic experience），意思是做这件事是为了事情本身，而不是为了奖励，也不是为了观众。如果没有人认可你在做什么，只要有可能，你仍然会每天都去做。尽管契克森米哈赖给它贴上了现代标签，但心流体验其实一点也不现代。纵观历史，人们曾描述过惊人相似的事情。例如，古希腊哲学家谈论过“幸福”（eudamonia），这是一种人类的
flourishing that came from deep engagement with meaningful activity. Artists during the Renaissance described divine inspiration, right? This trance-like creative state where their art seemed to come from something above them or around them rather than from them. Writers, Virginia Woolf, Ralph Waldo Emerson, Elizabeth Gilbert, they write about like, this rapture of creativity, this sense of like losing themselves in thought and creation, it's an out-of-body experience. And even in Eastern philosophies, Buddhism, Taoism, there's this idea of Wu Wei, which is effortless action, the act of doing without forcing, of being so attuned to what you're doing that it feels like it is flowing through you like a river. So we can kind of
繁荣状态，来自于对有意义活动的深度投入。文艺复兴时期的艺术家描述了神圣的灵感，对吧？这种如痴如醉的创造性状态，他们的艺术似乎来自于他们之上或周围的东西，而不是来自于他们自己。作家们，弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫（Virginia Woolf）、拉尔夫·沃尔多·伊 Emerson（Ralph Waldo Emerson）、伊丽莎白·吉尔伯特（Elizabeth Gilbert），他们写到这种创造力的狂喜，这种在思想和创造中迷失自我的感觉，这是一种灵魂出窍的体验。甚至在东方哲学中，佛教、道教中，也有“无为”的概念，也就是毫不费力的行动，不做作地去做的行为，与你正在做的事情高度契合，以至于感觉它像一条河一样流淌过你。所以我们可以
see, you know, the language for how we describe this has evolved, but the human experience has been the same for literal centuries. Like, Mihai's greatest contribution was giving this feeling a psychological framework, identifying its triggers, measuring it, understanding how it affects our brains and our emotions. It was by no means, though, a novel or new idea. This is something that different cultures, different people, different groups have named and have conceptualized for centuries, flow is just the new label. And I think it's quite a beautiful thing.
看到，你知道，我们描述这一现象的语言已经演变了，但人类的体验在几个世纪以来一直是一样的。就像，米哈里最大的贡献是为这种感觉提供了一个心理学框架，识别它的触发因素，衡量它，理解它如何影响我们的大脑和情绪。然而，这绝不是一个新颖或崭新的想法。这是不同文化、不同人群、不同群体几个世纪以来一直在命名和概念化的东西，“心流”只是一个新标签。而且我认为这是一件非常美妙的事情。
Like I honestly find that very comforting to know that like humanity has had this shared experienced across thousands and thousands of years across time and context and that flow is accessible to everyone and people have experienced like it's wonder before, you know, I was even alive. I just find it quite beautiful. Now, I did just say flow is accessible to absolutely. everyone, but it does tend to appear more often and more commonly in people who engage in structured challenges or creative practices. Musicians, writers, dances, athletes, gamers, programmers,
就像我老实说觉得这非常令人安慰，知道人类在几千年的时间里，跨越时间和语境，有着这种共同的体验，而且心流是对每个人都开放的，人们在我出生之前就已经体验过它的奇妙。我只是觉得这相当美妙。现在，我刚刚确实说过心流绝对是对每个人都开放的，但它确实往往更频繁、更普遍地出现在从事结构化挑战或创造性实践的人身上。音乐家、作家、舞蹈家、运动员、游戏玩家、程序员，
like these are the groups that often report entering a flow state more frequently. And it makes sense when you think about the conditions that help create it. Their activities usually involve clear goals, immediate feedback, and a gradual increase in skill over time. When a musician is practicing a piece, for example, they're constantly adjusting their performance based on what they hear. The challenge evolves with their ability. The same goes for athletes, the same goes for gamers, the same goes for riders. The feedback and the balance between difficulty and mastery keeps the brain engaged at that sweet spot. It's not only about the type of activity though, it's also about how you approach it that is
这些群体经常报告说他们更频繁地进入心流状态。当你思考有助于创造它的条件时，这就说得通了。他们的活动通常涉及清晰的目标、即时反馈以及随着时间的推移技能的逐渐提高。例如，当音乐家练习一首曲子时，他们会根据自己听到的声音不断调整自己的表现。挑战随着他们的能力而演变。运动员、游戏玩家、作家也是如此。反馈以及难度和精通度之间的平衡使大脑保持在那个最佳状态。不过，这不仅关乎活动的类型，还关乎你如何对待它，这
really, really critical. People who are intrinsically motivated, meaning they do things because they genuinely enjoy them, not because of external rewards. They tend to experience flow more often. Multiple studies and reviews show that intrinsic motivation fuels flow because it keeps your attention grounded in the process itself. We talked about this like dissipation of ego that your inner critic kind of silences during these moments. That's incredibly important for this process. You wouldn't be able to access flow if you were constantly thinking about how this thing
非常非常关键。内在驱动的人，也就是因为真心喜欢而做事，而不是为了外部奖励的人。他们往往更频繁地体验到心流。多项研究和综述表明，内在动机推动了心流，因为它让你的注意力扎根于过程本身。我们讨论过这种自我（ego）的消解，即你的内在批评者在这些时刻会安静下来。这对这个过程极其重要。如果你一直在思考你所做的事情将如何被评分，是否会得到人们的批准，是否会收到积极的反馈，人们是否会因为你做了这件事而更喜欢你，你就无法进入心流。这是不可能的。这必须是你为你自己、也仅仅为你自己所做的事情。也许它的好处是人们会庆祝它，认为你很棒，认为你很有才华。但即使你没有听到这种赞扬，你也会去做。
that you did was going to be graded or whether it was going to be approved by people, whether it was going to receive positive feedback, whether people will, the people are going to like you more because you did it. It's just not possible. This has to be something that you do for you and you alone. And maybe the benefits of it is that people celebrate it and think that you're amazing and think that you're talented. You would do it though even if you didn't hear that praise.
心理学家实际上发现，有一种特定类型的人更有能力激活这种，我猜，非自我批判、非外部验证的自我部分。这些人具有我们所说的“自体目的”（autotelic）特征。他们好奇心强。他们坚持不懈。他们不是很自我中心，并且对体验有着深深的开放性。这就是那种更有可能陷入心流状态的个人。
Psychologists actually find that there is a certain kind of person who is more able to activate this, I guess, non-self-critical, non-extern. validated part of themselves. And these are people who are high in what we call, again, autotelic traits. They're high in curiosity. They're high in persistence. They're not very self-centered and they have a deep openness to experience. That is the kind of individual who might be more likely to fall into a state of flow.
当然，尽管我们在基于表现的领域中看到了很多这种情况，比如外科医生、教师、软件工程师，但非常关键的一点是要知道，当人们在做自己热爱的事情时，任何人都可以体验到这一点，即使他们没有自体目的型人格。关于心流的真正真相是，它是人类的特权，它是人类的天赋，与其说它是关于你是谁，不如说是关于找到正确的投入方式。所以我们已经讨论了谁更有可能体验到心流、它的感觉如何、当我们处于其中时我们的大脑实际发生了什么，以及我们如何才能更多地获取它的属性和那种状态。
And whilst, of course, you know, we see that a lot in performance-based fields, surgeons, teachers, software engineers, like, it's very essential to know that anybody can experience this when they are doing something they love, even if they don't have an autotelic personality. The real truth about flow is that it is a human privilege, it is a human gift, it's less about who you are, and more about finding the right way to engage. So we've talked about who's more likely to experience flow, what it feels like, what is actually happening in our minds when we're in it, and how can we access its properties and that state more.
我们将稍作休息。当我们回来时，我们将探讨所有这些事情。请继续收听。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身以及培养抗挫力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We're going to take a short break. When we return, we're going to explore all of those things. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即“TWO percent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是Sam J.，我是Alex English。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图通过我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家来理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）合作的节目，大谈80年代的快克（crack）毒品。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊关于快克的日子，但是，对，对，对。不过为了让你们都知道。
you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but yeah, yeah, yeah. But just so you all know.
我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你补充完那句话。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？对。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世界上做个好人很重要？还是你做个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图。兄弟。绝对是。而且这是两个不同的信任级别。我希望你能真正地去做一个好人。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions. bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines），我们将就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了明显的矛盾之处。在她的一叙述中。这开启了长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。你伪造了这个特定测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了
Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies. in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took
大批互联网侦探才破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Maranini.
我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这还没完。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《The Girlfriends》的这个新季节里，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓我将是他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。请收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。
I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。那么，当你处于心流状态时，你的大脑到底发生了什么，让它变得如此奇妙？神经科学家阿尼·迪特里希（Arnie Detrich）将心流描述为一种“瞬时额叶功能低下”（transient hypofrontality）状态。这意味着什么？它基本上意味着你前额叶皮层的某些部分，尤其是那些负责自我监控和时间意识的部分，
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So what exactly is happening in your brain during flow that makes it so amazing? Well, the neuroscientist, Arnie Detrich, described flow. as a state of transient hypofrontality. What does that mean? It basically means that certain parts of your prefrontal cortex, especially those responsible for self-monitoring and time awareness,
实际上平静下来了或被下调了，这意味着你正在经历一种改变了的意识状态，而不是你的大脑处于一种疯狂地同时处理多件事情并伴随有批判性思维的状态，所有这些过程在一瞬间都消退了。你的注意力像激光一样聚焦在眼前的任务上。与此同时，多巴胺，这种与奖励和动机相关的神经递质，会上升。我们知道这会让你更享受这项任务。它还将帮助你提高创造力、持续注意力和模式识别能力，这意味着，
actually quiet down or are down-regulated, meaning that you are experiencing an altered state of consciousness, rather than your brain being in a state of frantically juggling multiple things at once and the accompanying critical thoughts that follow, all these processes kind of fade away for a moment. Your attention becomes laser focused on the task in front of you. At the same time, dopamine, the neurotransmitter associated with reward and motivation, rises. We know that's going to make you enjoy the task more. It's also going to help you with creativity, sustained attention, and pattern recognition, meaning that,
你更能进入状态。2014年发表在《Neuroimage》杂志上的一篇论文调查了27名参与者的样本，并将他们分成三个不同的实验组：心流组（参与者从事自动适应其技能水平的任务）、无聊组（任务太简单）和过载组（任务极具挑战性）。他们发现，经历心流的参与者同时表现出杏仁核神经活动减少。我们在播客中经常谈论杏仁核，以至于它现在基本上可以算是个共同主持了，但它负责威胁检测、情绪处理，甚至社交行为。心流期间该区域的活动？
you get more in this groove of things. A 2014 paper published in the journal Neuroimage investigated a sample of 27 participants and split them into three different experimental groups, either flow where participants engaged in tasks that automatically adjusted to their skill level, boredom where tasks were too easy, and overload where the task was way too challenging. They found that participants who experienced flow also showed decreased neural activity in the amygdala. We talk about the amygdala on the podcast so often it could basically be a co-host at this point, but it's responsible for threat detection, emotional processing, even social behavior. The activity in that area during flow?
微乎其微。这种神经转变也是为什么处于心流中的人经常报告说忘记了时间。你知道，你的内在时钟变慢了，没有什么可怕的东西会把你拉回现实。契克森米哈赖提出的一个非常有趣观点是，心流可能是他所谓的“美好生活”（the good life）的主要成分之一，这种生活不是由不断地快乐、不断地舒适来定义的，而是由定期的深度投入和意义时刻来定义的。从某种程度上说，这讲得通，因为心流只是让你从自己、从自我比较、从担忧、从试图表现中获得一个喘息的机会。这不是为了逃避生活，而是为了完全置身于生活之中，以至于所有这些
Minimal. This neural shift is also why people in flow often report losing track of time. You know, your internal clock is slowing down and there's nothing scary that's going to bring you back to the present. Something really interesting that Chig Sent Mihayi actually proposed is that flow might be one of the main ingredients of what he called the good life, a life that is not defined by constant pleasure, constant comfort, but by regular moments of deep engagement and meaning. And in a way, that makes sense because flow, just gives you a break from yourself, from self-comparison, from worry, from trying to perform. It's not about escaping life, but about being like completely inside of it such that all of
情绪干扰都不复存在。当你想到这一点时，老实说，我们处于这种状态是如此罕见，而且它并不是一种逃避现实的形式。显然，当你看着TikTok，当你玩手机、看电影、同时吃零食时，你可能会认为你处于心流状态。你可能无法分辨时间过去了多少。它可能感觉毫不费力。但你其实没有，因为这通常又是逃避现实的一种形式，而不是更深的情感联系。如果你脑子里在想：“我觉得自己在做有创造性的事情时从来没有过那种感觉，或者我以前能做到。我现在再也做不到了。我的大脑已经腐烂了”，你绝对不是唯一一个。心流听起来毫不费力。实际上它很难实现，尤其是现在，注意力经济基本上意味着有人在为你分心支付金钱。如果你被手机上的东西分心了，被屏幕上的东西、被广告、被任何东西分心了，有人正在靠你的分心赚钱。我们查看通知、切换标签、多任务处理。那种
these emotional distractions aren't there. When you think about that, like it's honestly so rare that we are in a state like this and it's not a form of escapism. Obviously, like when you're watching TikTok, when you're like on your phone, watching a movie, eating a snack at the same time, you might think that you're in a flow state. You probably can't tell how much time is passing. It probably feels very effortless. But you're not because it's often a form of, you know, again, escapism rather than deeper emotional connection. If you know you're thinking, I don't think I've ever felt that way when I'm doing something creative or I used to be able to do this. I can't get there anymore. I've rotted my
我们许多人发现自己身处其中的状态，实际上与心流生存所需的条件完全相反。心流需要不间断的专注，那种我们对一件事进行的深刻的、不间断的投入。我听了美国心理学会（American Psychological Association）由格洛丽亚·马克（Gloria Mark）博士主讲的播客，她谈到我们的注意力跨度现在平均只持续47秒。47-4-7秒。当我听到这个时，我惊呆了。这显然没有给你的难脑足够的时间完全沉浸在任何事情中。难怪心流越来越难遇到了，因为我们的集中力就像一块肌肉，它可能已经有点萎缩了。好消息是：
brain, you're definitely not alone. Flow sounds effortless. It's actually very hard to achieve, especially these days when the attention economy is basically meaning that there is money behind you being distracted. If you are distracted by something on your phone, buy something on the screen, by an advertisement, by anything like somebody is making money off of your distraction. We're checking notifications, we're switching tabs, we're multitasking. That can do. that a lot of us find ourselves in is actually the opposite of what flow needs to survive. Flow requires uninterrupted focus, that deep, unbroken engagement we have with one thing. And I listened to this podcast from the American Psychological Association featuring Dr. Gloria
专注、集中、连接，这是一种技能。就像任何技能一样，它是可以重建的。你可以训练你的大脑回到心流状态。第一步是保护你的注意力。为专注腾出时间，就像你为锻炼或社交活动腾出时间一样。这可能意味着关闭通知、把手机放在房间的另一头、在没有音乐、没有手机的情况下散步，仅仅去观察，仅仅拥有60分钟、30分钟来活在当下。你需要那种不间断的时间来重塑和重建。接下来，找到挑战的正确平衡，但要确保你在挑战自己。如果你总是做那些极其被动和无聊的事情，你是无法进入心流状态的。在手机上刷屏感觉很好。那里一直有低水平的多巴胺供你使用。除非你把自己置于那种能把你从我们所有人都发现自己身处的被动观察时刻中拉出来的条件和情境中，否则你永远无法实现真正的心流状态。
Mark, and she spoke about how, on average, our attention spans now last for just 47 seconds. 47-4-7 seconds. And that blew my mind when I heard it. That is clearly not enough time for your brain to fully immerse itself in anything. No wonder flow is becoming harder to come by because our concentration is like a muscle and it's probably atrophied a little bit. Here's the good news. focus, concentration, connectedness, that is a skill. And like any skill, it can be rebuilt. You can train your brain back into its flow state. One of the first steps is to protect your attention. Carve out time for focus the same way you would for a workout or for a social event. That might mean turning off notifications, setting your phone across the room, going on
心流在无聊和焦虑之间的甜蜜点中蓬勃发展，只需让事情变得稍微复杂一点，比你可能需要的稍微困难一点，迫使自己去做一些有点不寻常的事情。即使最初你觉得很难让自己去做这些事情，因为你知道接下来会发生的是这种迷人的精神状态。我的意思是，去买一些绘画用品，这样你晚上的唯一选择就不只是刷手机了。你有一个可以参与的创造性事情。去买一本数独书。去开办一个Substack。去为你自己创建一个网站或日记网站。只需做任何事情。垃圾手帐（Junk journal）。去参加一项运动，
to walk without music, without your phone, just to observe, just to have 60 minutes, 30 minutes to be present. You need that uninterrupted time to reform and rebuild. Next, find the right balance of challenge, but make sure you are challenging yourself. You cannot achieve a flow state if you are constantly doing things that are incredibly passive and boring. Scrolling on your phone, it feels great. There's like a low level of dopamine constantly available to you there. You're never going to achieve a true flow state unless you put yourself in conditions and situations that take you out of that passive kind of observational moment that all of us find
你不可能在心流中，同时也对你的日常生活完全被动和感到无聊。我知道听到这个可能有点不舒服，但如果某件事太简单了，你的大脑就没有必要达到那个参与水平。显然，选择对你重要的任务。当你纯粹为了外部验证而做某事时，心流很少发生。当它是对你有意义的事情时，它最有可能出现。我觉得这些天我们不断地觉得我们需要为了别人的享受、为了别人的安心或关注而生产、制作或发布东西。
ourselves in. Flow thrives in that sweet spot between boredom and anxiety and just making something a little bit more complex, a little bit more difficult than maybe you need to, pushing yourself to do things that are a little bit out of the ordinary. Even if initially it feels hard to bring yourself to do them because you know that what's coming is going to be this like enchanting state of mind. What I mean by that is like, go and invest in buying some painting supplies so that the only option for you at the end of the night is not just scrolling. You have a creative thing that you can engage in. Go and buy a Sudoko book. Go and start a substack. Go and create a website for yourself or like a journal website for yourself. Just like do anything. Junk journal. Like get yourself into a
在这些时刻，心流出现的可能性可能不是很大。我们需要那种内部和谐、内部验证、内在动机，推动我们继续前进，推动我们投入，推动我们参与，推动我们想要尝试。最后，要有耐心。心流不是你能强求的东西。有时它就是会发生。当它发生时，请记住它。
sport, you cannot be in flow and also completely passive and bored with your everyday life. I know it's kind of probably uncomfortable to hear, but if something is too easy, there's no point in your brain reaching that level of engagement. Choose tasks that also matter to you, obviously. Flow rarely happens when you're doing something purely for external validation. It's most likely to appear when it's something that's meaningful to you. I feel like these days we constantly feel like we need to produce or make or put stuff out there for other people's enjoyment and for other people's reassurance or attention.
把它记在心里。我要，这是一个疯狂的故事，但我记得我第一次体验心流是在，这听起来太矫情了，我第一次为大学作业制作播客剧集的时候。我知道我擅长这个、我想做这个、我会喜欢这个的原因有一半是因为我在上大学时为一门国际关系课程制作了这个播客。我清楚地记得我当时坐在哪里。我坐在安大略国立大学（ANU，我上的大学）图书馆的三楼。我坐在那里，不吃不喝，不去洗手间，
It's probably not so likely that flow is going to appear in those moments. We need that internal harmony, that internal validation, that intrinsic motivation, pushing us to keep going, pushing us to engage, pushing us to engage, pushing us to want to try. Finally, be patient. Flow isn't something you can force. Sometimes it just happens. And when it does, please remember it.
我想呆了五个小时，只为了制作这个播客。当你找到心流时，我认为你也找到了目标。每个人都想找到自己擅长的事、梦想的工作、你知道，自己来这里的意义。心流就像是你找到这一切的钥匙。当你找到心流时，你就找到了目标。所以慢下来，尽量不要让自己分心。尽量不要强迫自己进入这种状态。只需倾听你的环境、倾听你的感受、倾听你的精神状态，心流就会更容易到来。随之而来的，还有你在生活中可能一直在寻找的许多其他答案。考虑到这一点，感谢你的收听。感谢收听这期迷你的加更节目。
Keep it in mind. I will, this is like a wild story, but I remember one of the first times I experienced flow was, and this is going to sound so cheesy, the first time I made a podcast episode for a uni assignment. Half the reason where I knew that this was going to be something that I was good at and that I was going to want to do and that I was going to love was because I made this podcast for like an international relations course when I was at uni. And I remember exactly where I was sitting. I was sitting on the third floor of this library at A&U, the university I went to. And I sat there without eating, without drinking, without going to the bathroom.
希望你喜欢。如果你听到了这里，请在下方留个小评论。你什么时候会体验到心流？你认为你的心流状态与你的目标一致吗？是或否。我认为是一致的。我认识其他人，他们认为心流更符合他们的热情所在，他们永远不想靠它赚钱，或者这将永远是他们的逃避方式或爱好。所以我想听听你的想法和意见。同时确保你关注了我们。点击订阅按钮。点击那个什么按钮？
for I think five hours just making this podcast. And when you find flow, I think you also find purpose. Everybody wants to find what they're going to be great at, their dream job, you know, what they're here for. Flow is like your key to finding that. When you find flow, you find purpose. So slow down, try not to distract yourself. Try not to force yourself into it. Just listen to your environment, listen to your feelings, listen to your mental state, and flow will come a lot easier. And with that, so many other answers that you might be looking for in your life. So with that in mind, thank you for listening. Thank you for listening to this mini bonus episode.
我想这只是一个关注按钮。点击关注按钮，这样你就知道新节目什么时候发布了。今年12月我们有一些精彩的节目即将推出。我刚刚采访了关于整形手术心理学的节目。我还采访了另一个关于野心陷阱的节目。有太多好东西要推出了。所以请确保你在周围。并在Instagram上关注我们：@That Psychology Podcast。如果你想看更多幕后花絮
I hope you enjoyed it. If you made it this far, please leave a little comment down below. When do you experience flow? And do you think that your flow state is aligned with your purpose? yes or no. I think it is. I know other people who think that flow alliance with more so what they're passionate with that they never want to make money off of or that is always going to be their escape or their hobby for them. So I want to hear your thoughts and your opinions. Make sure as well that you are following us. Hit the subscribe button. Hit the what is the button?
以及我们在做的事情，或者与社区互动，那里有太多的机会让你这样做。同时也感谢我们的研究助理莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对这期节目的贡献。她太棒了。她太厉害了。我们非常感激她。话虽如此，我们很快就会和你交谈。保持安全。保持善良
I think it's just a follow button. Hit the follow button so that you know when new episodes come out. We have some amazing episodes coming up this December. I just interviewed again. on the psychology of plastic surgery. I interviewed another one on the ambition trap. Like there's so much good stuff coming. So make sure that you are around for that. And follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you want to see more behind the scenes stuff
对自己温柔一点。回头见。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是Sam J.，我是Alex English。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并通过我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家来试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
and what we're getting up to or engage with the community, there are so many opportunities for you to do that over there. Thank you as well to our research assistant Libby Colbert for her contributions to this episode. She is fantastic. She is amazing. We appreciate. her so much. But with all that being said, we will talk to you very soon. Stay safe. Be kind
欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全进行的诚实对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。
and be gentle to yourself. See you later. On the Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试结果两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身以及培养抗挫力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即“TWO percent”。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
这里是《陷入爱河》。我是斯科茨代尔警局的劳拉。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于受到了惩罚。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《陷入爱河》播客。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中。
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app,
我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中展现出的心理韧性、健康以及培养抗压能力的迹象。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio应用上收听《2%》。
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends.
Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的诈骗犯约过会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是这么说，相信你的女性朋友。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
听女性朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。